how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu today
we're going to talk about some dr
strange in the multiverse of madness
casting news and we'll be talking about
all of the new characters that we can
expect to see in this film
now much like the reports for captain
marvel 2 sort of being a kind of
mini avengers film most of the mcu films
moving forward
aren't going to involve just one
character but
mcu films from here on out are actually
going to be pretty big movies involving
multiple different characters and doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness is
no
exception we already know that wanda is
going to go into doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and the events
from the one division show are going to
directly
lead up to doctor strange 2. plus we
have some other characters that are
going to be joining the master of
the mystic arts and we'll talk about
them all in this video and if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
stay up to date on all the latest mcu
news and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a gambit
funko pop all you gotta do to enter
subscribe
like the video leave a comment down
below on picking a winner on monday
so this report is coming from
thedirect.com and according to the
report they can confirm the existence of
an official marvel studios casting grid
stating that the studio is now casting a
puerto rican actress
ages 12 to 15 years old for an upcoming
movie
this casting is for the role of america
chavez aka
miss america and doctor strange in the
multiverse of
madness now this isn't actually the
first time that we've heard that miss
america is going to be in multiverse of
madness and there are two
very interesting points to her showing
up in this film
and one is her powers her main ability
is the ability
to be able to kick open a hole to a
different reality this allows her and
her teammates who are with her to go
through the multiverse and go
into different realities now again we
know in the one division series that
wanda is going
to create or at least be in different
realities as well
and we know and it's been confirmed that
the one of vision events will lead right
up to the events in doctor strange
too and according to this report and a
past report
miss america is actually going to be a
pretty big supporting character in the
film so based off of everything that we
know so far it seems like
miss america could be used by doctor
strange to open different realities and
maybe go in and get
wanda regardless we know the film of
course is multiverse of
madness so miss america's powers of
being able to go into different
realities through the multiverse will
definitely come in handy in helping
doctor strange and it definitely does
seem like he's going to need some help
because it has been confirmed
that baron mordo is going to be
returning to the film we also have evan
peters who played quicksilver in the fox
universe joining one division as well
and it's highly speculated that he's
going to be playing mephisto
emma fisto and doctor strange have a
pretty interesting history together
and not to mention of course all of the
talks of nightmare being the main
villain of the film as well so it seems
like doctor strange is definitely going
to have his hands full which is why miss
americana is going to be helping him out
and then
we also have clea helping him out as
well
kalia has been reported to be in the
film for a very long time now clea is
another sorceress and is also a romantic
love interest of dr stephen strange so
right now this truly is turning into a
very
mystic movie we have doctor strange the
master of the mystic arts we have wanda
who was in extremely
powerful which which we'll call her
because she's going to take on the
persona of the scarlet witch mephisto
could be in the film miss america is
going to be in the film
khalia's going to be in the film and
then we have baron mordo and there's the
possibility that nightmare could be the
main villain so
pretty packed cast with a lot of awesome
people but the second point of miss
america being in this film
is that she's going to be very young
which means they're most likely going to
use her to start to set up the young
avengers plenty of other young avengers
are going to start to be set up in the
mcu
we have the twins of wanda vision wiccan
and speed coming in the one division
series kate bishop
is coming to the hawkeye series miss
marvel is getting her own tv show
cassie lang the daughter of scotland
coming in as stature
and then of course there's always the
possibility that harley keener
comes back as iron lad so a lot of
exciting things coming to the mcu and a
lot is going to be happening in doctor
strange 2
the multiverse of madness so let me know
what you think about this report and let
me know who you would like to see appear
in multiverse of madness be sure to let
me know in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
stay up to date on all things relating
to the mcu
for live updates you can follow me on
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof
you